[Music]
if anybody knows how to start a party
it's my brother andrew
or should i say
the jig conductor
it's fine it's so cute it's so good no
mom if anybody sees that i'm gonna get
put on a watch list
i can't believe college is over you have
a job now or we're not allowed to talk
about jobs at the bottom instant party
so you either don't have a job or you
have a bad job how much does a party
starter get paid i wonder
i have a bad job yeah
honey i'm not just saying this because
i'm your mother i feel like you're way
ahead of the
[Music]
we're not feeling it right now how about
i bet you 300 i can get her on the dance
floor i will give you a thousand dollars
[Music]
she really likes you i really like her
tonight is the night that you and lola
dance your booties off
oh
i don't know how to moonwalk
do you think he would be a good sitter
for you i do not do well with sitters
but i think it might be a bit different
with andrew
do you want to meet my hamster
yeah
i want to thank you for being so kind to
lola easiest thing in the world i'm
having more fun now than i did the whole
night
[Music]
do you have a husband i have a fiance i
hear you're a great party starter i hear
you're a great professional lawyer
i want us to figure out after college
[Music]
giving your heart to somebody is the
most
perplexing thing
you can't just decide that you love
somebody yes you can no you can't yes
you can
we don't need you to babysit anymore why
lots of reasons
are you drunk right now son everything's
just little bits
growing up is hard
is he your soul mate do you believe in
soulmates i think we all have a ton of
soul mates how many soul mates for you
like four how many do you have like 1200
[Music]
[Music]
you